[Music]
let's go to leslie in
grand rapids michigan what's up leslie
hey how you doing we were just rocking
onto the break of dawn what about you
living the dream
are you what are you talking about is it
good there you go
there you go more of a nightmare so
what's going on yeah
uh well i appreciate you taking my call
of course thanks for calling
so i got a tough one i do my best not to
be emotional because i really want to
hear what you have to say hey be as
emotional as you need to you can always
go back and listen
so
my husband and i
lost our daughter to cancer
seven months ago
yikes
nine months old holy smokes
yup wow what was your name what was your
name
sadie sadie nine months
yup
what kind of cancer uh
she was born with leukemia
god almighty so is it in utero
yeah but we didn't know until she was
about five months old so she fought for
about four months and um it just became
too much for treatment so
oh my gosh that little bitty baby
yeah so we have a lot going on in our
lives and um so that was did you say
seven months ago
yeah it was seven months ago okay so
just pause right there
what's the last seven months been how
are you and your husband doing
um you know it's a struggle every day
for sure um
you know everybody else goes on with
their lives and it still seems like
we're stuck yeah
yep you know we're still doing our thing
and going to work and just trying to put
one foot in front of the other
i've i've
found that after month four
five or six or so
when the calls stop and the tech stop
and the casserole stop
that's when that
grief becomes heavy heavy heavy and
really dark
gray right yeah is it fair is that what
you're experiencing
yeah it's it's definitely uh
similar to that it's very difficult
for sure
so then you say that's not all what's
next
no so on top of that
um i'm actually currently pregnant
four months pregnant with our soon-to-be
son
wow
we have a lot going on yeah
wow wow wow okay
yeah and so all signs pointing to
healthy everything good with sun
um
so far but they won't be able to test
him for cancer until he's born
so
okay i'm gonna put a pin in what you
just said
okay and then we'll circle back to it
all right but i don't remember this
moment because i'm gonna bring it back
up okay
okay all right so keep going
all right um so a couple questions that
i have for you is
how do we process our feelings of our
grief while simultaneously allowing
ourselves to feel joy for this new child
that's coming
we find ourselves you know the outside
world is
so happy for us and it makes it seem
like they think that this new baby is
gonna
you know make us happy again and solve
our problems and
it's hard to be
excited you know when we're still
grieving
and then my other question was
how do we
more so probably for me i don't know
about my husband but how do we process
our fear of our new baby being a
constant reminder of the baby that we
lost yeah
do you have any other kids
no this was our first first child okay
um can i ask you a few questions before
we dig in yeah okay
um this isn't always but sometimes often
um
i've sat with women who blame themselves
or like my body did this thing
do you have any sort of self-blame here
or do you understand that the rare
just struck by lightning nature of some
of this
no yeah i don't i don't feel that um
good good her cancer was a chromosomal
thing and not a genetic thing okay um so
it just was
in the cards for her okay
which is both a relief and terrifying
because she's in the cards for all of us
right and that
it it brings
to light how precious every single
breath is right
right
um okay so
a couple of things
number one
i want you to separate
these two
kids
and right now with this pregnancy being
on top of what feels like just such a
recent pregnancy and everything is so
charged it feels like one constant
stream like one continuous
um
continuous day
and it's two separate people
okay yeah
and i know that's hard but it's
something i want you to lean towards
because when you lean into that a little
bit it will be there will become
there'll be a light that comes through
the crack between the two
okay and that's how you're gonna you're
gonna honor
and love sadie
you're gonna remember sadie you're gonna
see the bravery and you're going to talk
about her bravery and how she fought
and
those precious moments you had when she
grabbed your finger those things that
you know you can still feel that
pressure on your finger right you still
feel it
and
you're going to be able to
celebrate your son
as two separate events it it feels like
right now that all you're going to think
about is and what i'm telling you on the
other side of having two kids it feels
that way and it's gonna be different
okay you will remember sadie you'll
remember the experience you'll remember
the fear
and so earlier when i asked you how is
he healthy your answer was so far
because here's what you're doing now now
you're waiting for the next shoe to drop
my guess is you haven't
you haven't fully exhaled since you
found out you were pregnant is that fair
yeah that's fair okay
so
have you and your husband
you know i say this all the time and and
um
it's not a catch-all but man it's such a
gift have you and your husband written
sadie a letter
um no not nothing like that okay
so what i want both of you to do is i
want your husband to write sadie a
letter
one page two page ten pages
i want him to tell her
about his childhood i want him to tell
her about how excited he felt when he
found out that y'all were having a baby
when he found out i was going to be a
girl
um
i want him to write to sadie and tell
him how scared he was when he found out
that she was sick
how brave he thought she was
um and this is a this could be a one
letter it could be a couple of letters
um it might be hey here is here's i just
want you to get to know your dad
and it could be hey uh here's what i
experienced when you weren't doing well
i want you to know how much i loved you
and i know you're only seven months old
six months old five months old but
here's what i was experiencing
and
then on the back end here's how much i
miss you i just want you to know that i
miss you right and i want you to do the
same thing
and then i want you all to read your
letters to each other
okay
grief has a way of splitting people up
because everybody grieves differently
how's your marriage right now
our marriage is is good um
i think the fact that you know we were
the only ones that could be there for
her and we were the only ones that got
to experience
the situation
we lean on each other in that way
because nobody else understands what we
went through right have you joined a
group uh grief group with parents who've
lost young kids
um no okay you know i haven't really
found any yet but i i
oh so strongly recommend that you do
that
okay
i won't walk through my personal stuff
but i'll tell you it's having
conversations with folks has been a
lifeline for me
yeah okay
um it's so so so important i didn't
experience near what you experienced but
loss of losses losses loss and i'll tell
you is having people that you can that
just like you just said it you talk to
them and they go yeah i get it i know
and they talk to you back and you go oh
gosh you know you know what i mean and
it makes you feel a little bit less
alone
which makes your
brain calm down just a little bit and
then you can be a little more open and
you can breathe a little bit more deeply
and it begins to that's the road the
path to healing
okay yeah
and then
i want you and your husband to write
letters to this new little boy
about how excited you are here's what
i'm telling you to do and it's gonna
sound bonkers i want you to go all in on
him
because what you're
man i can get emotional think about this
you're going to want to hedge your bets
right
don't do that go all in on him risk
getting
hurt again like you were last time
because it's probably statistically
speaking it's not going to happen right
i mean we hope
see there you go now you are waiting for
the next thing to happen and what i'm
telling you is statistically speaking
it's not gonna happen again
you're gonna have a wonderful excited
joyful
bonkers little baby boy
pooping and peeing and yelling
everything and
you know what i mean
exactly what you hoped for
don't hedge your bets this is your baby
is your child go all in
and i want you and your husband to share
in
that fear
i'm nervous and i'm scared and also that
joy it's okay to feel joy it feels like
joy for your new son
is like you're
cheating on you're abandoning your
daughter
and they're not mutually exclusive
like you know i mean like it feels like
if you're joyful and you're like oh this
is going to be so great that somehow
you're disrespecting your daughter does
it feel that way right yeah i mean i
understand completely what you're saying
tell me in your own words
i just feel like you know each day that
moves on and
each experience that we move forward
with it's just like another step
away from her yeah
so here's what i want you to do
are you listening leslie
yep i want you to let her go
she's gonna stay a part of you she
always will always always will
don't you let her go
and it's going to take time that's going
to take healing
it is not a disrespe it's not
disrespectful to her it's not a sign
that you are leaving her
if you experience joy if you laugh
if you
cheer and are excited about your new son
it's both
and yeah cause you're gonna love sadie
for the rest of your life
that tough powerful strong beautiful
little girl is gonna be with you forever
i appreciate that
i'm telling you
you don't trust me do you i know you
don't trust me it's okay though
no you don't have to you're that far
trust me you don't have to um
you don't have to i just want you to
know
joy will come again
yeah
is there like a way to like process the
trauma of you know what we saw visually
and
you know how to
not be have that like be a constant
reminder like every day of what we went
through yeah so is there like a
yeah there's several techniques i'm
gonna give you the high level one okay
probably you're gonna um if you get uh
caught on looping thoughts on that
rumouring thoughts of i remember that
baby were you with her when she passed
away
yeah and it wasn't a it wasn't a
peaceful death by any means that's right
and that haunts you
yeah
and often when we think about loved ones
that we lost especially children
we think about them now
as though they're still experiencing the
last moment that we held them
right and sadie's at peace
right now she's at
that last moment you spent with her that
ugliness and that grittiness and that
terror
it's over
okay
the the top level high level
um is it's from david kessler just the
grief master i'd recommend at some point
maybe not now but you and your husband i
want you to read finding meaning
together we'll link to it in the show
notes it's the single greatest book on
grief i've ever read
um and it's about the loss of a child
okay
um
but he gives this example and i've done
it on the show i haven't done it in a
while but he asks everybody in the
audience an audience of parents who've
lost a child
to
imagine i think it was a purple elephant
he said picture a purple elephant in
your mind
and then they have in their mind and
then he tells them to open their eyes
and he says there i proved it to you you
can control your thoughts
here's what happens
we get that picture that just lightning
bolts into our mind
of those last two minutes those last six
minutes says last two months
the moment they lightning bolt into our
head
we have a choice
am i gonna meditate on that on the
terror on the fear on my tears on that
how scary it all was or
am i going to remember
holding her
and i'm going to remember the quiet
nights
the
time in front of the fire the
breastfeeding nights the time she was
bouncing with dad and laughing a little
bit am i gonna remember that
and you get to choose which one of those
and over time if you just like my wife
she'll hear me i'll walk through the
living room i'll be like nope that means
something popped into my head and i'm
just telling my body i'm not doing it
i'm not doing it and she'll laugh like
she'll be like oh gosh john she doesn't
even ask me what it was she doesn't want
to know what it but i'm conscious about
i'm not going to meditate on that
i'm not going to let that just loop in
my head i'm going to have a picture
that's going to replace it
and so you can picture those last couple
of minutes in the hospital
or you can picture you can go nope i'm
not thinking of that i'm thinking of
this
and what i'll tell you is over time your
body when you conju when you think of
sadie
it will bring back the pictures that you
tell it to that you meditate on and it
will default not to the hard stuff
because the hard stuff just trying to
remind you hey this happened this could
happen again it could happen again it
could happen
again and you can train your brain
we're remembering beauty
we're remembering joy
and it's a battle for a while and it's
hard because you feel like you're
letting your daughter go and i'm telling
you let her go she's going to be with
you whether you
she's going gonna be with you she's a
part of you
let her go
thank you okay
i appreciate it we love you leslie and
i'm so so sorry
but
you and your husband write those letters
y'all read them to each other
and then i want you to each write a
letter about how excited you are to meet
your son
if you're brave i want you to mail me a
copy of that letter
or email me a copy of that letter
and if you don't want me to read on the
air i won't if you do i'd love to
because i'd love to let everybody know
how i lived everybody here
the words of a mom who's both
broken-hearted and both brimming with
optimism and joy a mom who's both
terrified of the next shoe that's gonna
drop and both hopeful
i'd love to read that letter out it
would bless
there's not a lot of people listening to
the show but actually you know what i'm
not even making a joke of this one it
would bless a lot a lot of people a lot
of people listen to the show it would
really be a gift thank you for your
bravery leslie we're worth man thinking
about you and your family